that's what i call attitude praise from
a legendary bass player Alfonso Johnson
played with Santana Genesis weather
report and many others here he's giving
amateur musicians some pointers to be
able to touch someone do the music to
reach into someone and change the way
that they feel about that moment that's
the good bass player a good musician
period the location is Warwick bases
factory in mock notation Saxony
and Peter versa founded the company in
1982 at first hardly anyone took notice
of the basis made in Germany English
name or not
this is the instrument that made the
breakthrough it belonged to John
Entwistle former bass player for the who
in the late 1980s damn I serve us back
then it was real rock and roll weather
at the trade fairs or parties going
through the night or when John trashed a
room at the Savoy Hotel in Frankfurt
frankfurt him with a boy who dated
estimates a leak even if it got smashed
to pieces on stage a Warwick in the
hands of a superstar brought new
customers every base produced by warwick
in Germany is one of a kind the wood
used the design and the number of
pickups are a matter of the buyers
preference and the price a base can cost
anywhere from 2,500 to 25 thousand euros
the orders range from 50 to 150
instruments per month not enough to keep
the company afloat Warwick has its more
basic models made in China and Korea
under the company's strict supervision
to make sure they live up to its quality
standards
una dos reproduction without our
production in China we couldn't survive
because to a great extent we finance our
location in Germany from the profits we
make on the models from China we have to
have that financial boost in with no but
you should bear in mind that our product
development our creativity is here the
creativity in 1995 hans-peter Wilfer
moved the company from Bavaria to Saxony
close to the Czech border
he says he happened upon mark no kyojin
by chance the town has a long tradition
for instrument making at one time it was
the foundation of its prosperity
nowadays production is on a modest scale
even after 20 years the factory still
doesn't quite fit into the townscape but
Warwick has put mark no occasion back on
the international music scenes map
especially for one week in the year when
30 world famous musicians get together
with some 80 amateurs not all of them
play Warwick basis but the gathering
serves its purpose even so she believed
a toy does I'm convinced that in the
long term this is a smart marketing
strategy in for big marketing variety of
the ocean it has far-reaching effects
the youngster he does because the ones
who've been here takes something away
with not just an advertising slogan or a
brochure they take an experience with
them seen a man a deepness mid and that
experience goes on right through the
night when the local pub is turned into
a stage
big names in jazz and rock jam with
unknowns and this is where it's
happening